c'est l'un des soixante dix neuf
satellites de jupiter une lune que l'on
observe depuis très longtemps qu'on
imaginait abriter d'immenses océan
recouvert d'une épaisse couche de glace
et peut-être même de la vie il a fallu
attendre quarante ans après les leçons
de voyageurs mais la preuve est
maintenant faite il y à bien deux loups
sur europe 1 sous forme dimanche gr ii
va pas qui fracturent ici et là la
banquise glacé ce qui est vraiment
impressionnante cette nouvelle c'est que
c'est la première détection de la vapeur
d'eau mais le rêveur la première claire
détection la vapeur d'eau sur un objet à
l'extérieur de la terre la nasa à
l'origine la découverte à utiliser le
grand télescope keck pour repérer des
geysers puis analyser la composition
chimique de la vapeur pour les
spécialistes c'est un grand pas de
franchi les plus grandes quêtes
présentement l'astrophysique c'est la
quête pour la vie à l'extérieur de la
terre est une des composantes
principales pour avoir la vie s'est il
faut de l'eau liquide
en effet pour que la vie est une chance
de se développer il faut absolument une
source d'énergie
un groupe d'éléments chimiques précis et
de l'eau sous forme liquide e repas
possède donc les 3 mais y at il aussi de
la vie sous la glace
on peut penser à des équivalents de ce
que l'on trouve dans les fonds marins
très profond sur notre planète donc une
vie microbienne peut-être quelque chose
d'un peu plus élaboré évidemment on n'a
aucune confirmation qui est de la vie
mais on a une piste très intéressante
pour en savoir plus on a déjà prévu
certains scénarios comme utiliser la
sonde europe aux clippers dont le
lancement est prévu en 2025 pour
survoler des geysers ci a du matériel
organique sur du matériel biologique qui
profitent des geysers qui remonte la
colonne d'eau et qui est éjecté on
pourrait aller capturer ou enfer
recueillir un peu de cette vapeur d'eau
est peut-être décelé des formes
microscopiques de vie
l'objectif peut sembler lointain mais il
est réaliste et réalisable
les dernières années il ya tellement eu
d'immenses découverte dans ce domaine
que ce soit dans le système solaire les
exoplanètes que cela m'étonnerait pas
que dans 10 6
d'ici quelques dizaines d'années on va
avoir des preuves concrètes de
l'existence de décines de vie possible
ici normand grondin radio canada
montréal